you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome Eric
Horvath's technical fellow and director
of Microsoft Research Lab thank you and
let me bring out my esteemed panel Salam
Baracus Carla Gomes Percy Liang and
Grisha on a day well welcome to the
panel on AI people in society will will
be discussing questions and issues that
are coming to the fore with challenges
and opportunities at the intersection of
AI people in society over the last
decade growing excitement about
harnessing AI to empower extend to
protect us has been tempered in ways in
many ways by rising concerns about the
potential rough edges and adverse
outcomes whether inadvertent or directed
now some folks fear the rise of super
intelligences and the loss of control
the AI systems other folks focus on
expectations that AI advances will have
influences that will be detrimental for
workforce through labor and to will
amplify inequity among people on
near-term issues people are worried
about rough edges with the concerns with
fair accountable and transparent AI the
notions of there being deep biases
buried in data sets that are leading to
unfair inferences other concerns include
coming to the fore include legal and
ethical issues with recisions made often
in a split second but autonomous systems
that make key trade-offs about sensitive
issues and questions about whose utility
function is represented in these systems
and shouldn't end-users rep references
be represented in them and on the front
of civil liberties we have groups like
the ACLU and others where the concerns
about rising threats to civil liberties
being new forms of surveillance or Sofia
the large
scale pursuit of data resources in
accordance with building AI systems for
various commercial goals so there's a
few of many concerns rough edges and
discussions being provoked by the
successes we see in AI will be
discussing these questions and others we
induce our panelists starting on my
right is Grisha run a day she's a
researcher at Microsoft Research she
just became an MS Rai person but she was
formerly in the in the adaptive systems
in interaction with their theory groups
at our Redmond lab kiriza did her PhD
work at UC Berkeley did her
undergraduate work at MIT and her
research interests include control of
autonomous systems and safety issues
around that information theory wireless
communications crowdsourcing and other
topics to her left is Percy the yang and
assistant professor at Stanford
University Percy did his PhD also at
Berkeley he did his bachelor's also at
MIT saving different classes maybe and
his research because as many of you know
from his contributions this week include
natural language semantics developing
machine learning methods that for rich
latent structures from limited
supervision an idea that's rising in
importance and we're getting some more
competency in that space over time he
actually won the itch sky computers a
broad award last year slow misters
fellowship and most importantly will be
for us a Microsoft Research faculty
fellowship a couple years ago
welcome Percy next to Perseus alone
Baracus along a fence that were very
proud to say a couple of years in the
postdoc in our New York City lab where
he's provided leadership in the area of
fairness accountability and transparency
oft we're helping to stand up a whole
community in this space starting at the
workshop in our conference he's also
involved I had been involved with the
center of information technology policy
at Princeton University and he did his
doctorate in media culture communication
at NYU where he remains
beef nation law Institute and then call
it gums to salons left is fifty-three
science and director of Institute for
computational stainability at Cornell
like we've known Carlos many years as a
fabulous researcher in optimization
satisfiability some should attack some
of the hardest problems in AI somewhat
np-hard problems was with interesting
methods and heuristics and optimizations
and a few years ago she became a leader
in this whole realm of applying AI for
material science sustainability in many
areas that had not been touched by these
methods before and leads up an
expedition that NSF funded to create a
network of related researchers in
computational sustainability so we're
going to basically just have a seven
minute statement from each of our
panelists leaving time for questions and
comments among ourselves on the stage
here as well as opening up to the
audience given this topic is an
interesting one to many people and there
are lots of opinions questions concerns
and and feelings about some of these
issues so let's start to my left with
Girija well thanks Eric
thanks for the invitation to be here so
I wanted to bring up two different
issues to the discussion today and the
first one is something that has gotten a
lot of attention recently especially
following the recent u.s. presidential
election and this is of course the fact
that algorithms and BOTS can now
influence public opinion and you know be
used to spread all kinds of propaganda
and we've seen the effect of this not
just in the US but also for example in
the recent French election or it was
used to influence voting during the
breakfast vote and just to give you some
examples of the kinds of stories that
were circulated on social media during
the US election for examples there were
stories with headlines such as Oh
Hillary sold weapons to Isis or Obama
has banned the Pledge of Allegiance
schools and these kind of stories on
social media I think are something
that's really important to think about
of course there's the implications that
have gotten recent attention about
Russian involvement which makes people
very interested and it's not as though
you know this kind of misinformation is
new it's been there all along but what
social media and the Internet are now
allowing is even people without access
to large-scale television networks or
publishing you know printing presses can
influence thousands of opinions and they
can do that in an automated way and can
target users using the same algorithms
that we use for targeting ads to
different people so the question of
course is you know what can we do about
this
as a community and how can we address
the challenges that this brings up and
so the first question of course is you
know can be identify what we would think
of as fake news or harmful information
and this becomes challenging given that
you know certain articles that we've
looked at better you know we think of as
fake news are often very strongly worded
opinion pieces where there is nothing
that is false that is actually written
but it's just strongly suggested and
then you know in contrast you have
things like the onion which are known to
be satire so they're knowingly saying
false things or you have breaking news
and very reputable news outlets that is
you know not presented with a lot of
evidence so this suggests you want some
kind of human labeling to be able to
actually deal with the problem but then
as soon as you get human labeling we all
bring with us our own personal
preferences and personal biases and how
do you prevent for example the same
problem happening again where another
malicious agent then automate the
labeling so that now you label stories
however you want just by having lots of
agents and once maybe you even identify
these stories there's a question of well
what do you do about this and I think
this is something where the partnership
on AI could play a very influential
roll by bringing together different
large you know players in the space to
come to a consensus and how we can
identify harmful influences on our
society without being worried about
political bias or personal preferences
and I think maybe by working together on
some of these issues we might actually
be able to present a unified front to be
able to tackle some of these things
there's a bunch of work I know that
there's work in the NLP community for
example that's being done to address
this you know different platforms are
coming up with different laboring
strategies but I think there's a bunch
of interesting questions in this space
that that we need to think about in
particular for example you want to make
sure that you're not in any way
censoring free speech so you would want
to publish your algorithm for having for
identifying fake news but of course this
doesn't scent advises people to maybe
gain your system so what are the
trade-offs that are we need to think
about here and in the last few minutes I
had I actually wanted to kind of switch
gears and talk about a second issue that
I I've been thinking a lot about and
this has to do with autonomous agents
not in the online world but in the
physical world and Barbara mentioned
this you know in the context of
self-driving cars in her talk yesterday
briefly and you know if this came up
just a few weeks ago when I was visiting
Kerry Park in a much smaller kind of
baby way where there was a huge tourist
crowd you know looking at the skyline
and Mount Ranier
and suddenly someone launched two drone
up into the air and everyone's attention
was diverted to the drone because they
were curious what I was doing but also
because it was so over powered by the
gusts of wind that it was wildly going
everywhere and people started backing
away from the railing because they were
they were worried I was going to hit
them in the face and this brings up
questions of both what is the
responsibility of someone who is
launching such a drone and what kind of
you know safety and stability guarantees
should we as engineers be
giving for these kinds of devices that
are going to be released into
uncertainty environments they might not
you know behave according to the models
that they were certified under the
environment might not be according to
specification what kind of failsafe
methods do we need to have when our
expected specifications are not met for
the conditions and I think there's a
wide set of interesting questions that
we need to think about here both on the
Samanta liability side but also just the
technical challenges I think are
incredibly interesting I think maybe
Percy wants to build on some of that and
we can go from there
but I guess it's a cue Percy you take
them yeah so building on Girija is so
going first I'm really happy to be here
so thank you Eric for inviting me so
building on the idea of kind of
reliability of a I systems I want to
make it I guess a few comments about
that so it's very clear today that AI
has kind of gone from kind of what I
call a kind of envy ville
- sorry in vitro - kind of in in vivo in
the sense that you know when I was in in
so in grad school we would you know
write papers and we were kind of do
these experiments but it was much more
of an academic pursuit and these days
you know yesterday we heard Harry Shum
talk about how AI really should be
everywhere and all the Microsoft
products are going to have AI and them
so the pervasiveness of AI in the real
world I think actually raises some
really interesting challenges and also
opportunities for research I'm going to
talk a little bit about kind of a suit
the security angle earlier today there
was an excellent breakout session on you
know security so many of these comments
will be kind of echoing some of the
discussion there and the I guess the
high level way to think about it is that
a lot of what we the culture and kind of
progress in AI has been about okay we
build something and then we see what it
does and
you know we recognizes it was good but I
think security actually kind of requires
a very different mindset it's not about
kind of what's happening now but it's
about what could possibly happen and we
all know that and kind of security being
by being the reactive instead of kind
proactive is kind of a recipe that
doesn't work very well so I want to
point out you know two types of kind of
attacks that I think are interesting one
are these adversarial examples which
many of you probably have seen so the
concrete I think maybe this was four
years ago
Ian and colleague Ian Goodfellow and
colleagues had papers showing how you
take a state of art object recognition
system it classifies images an image
correctly and then you can add
imperceptible changes to this image
causing the classifier to break down and
with high confidence and classify you
know and the school bus is an ostrich
for example and this is and so that's
fine but what's actually more
interesting is that they show that this
was kind of very robust to variations in
you know data set variations and models
they transferred against different
models you didn't even need the model at
all only neat black box access and you
know it's so it seems like actually kind
of a fundamental problem that we've kind
of you know exposed which offers a lot
of kind of research opportunities one
thing that's kind of interesting is that
there's been a lot of papers on you know
showing I can defend against this and
then other papers saying no you can't
here's an attack actually recently
earlier on July 12th there was a
archived paper that came out saying no
need to worry about adversarial examples
for autonomous driving and then five
days later on there is a blog post Alba
o open AI showing that well actually
here's just a bunch of examples that
actually you know breaks all the
assumptions so the assumption with that
if you've got images from different view
you would be safe but it turns out that
it's not safe either so you know I think
this kind of reactive mode is is you
know limiting and in some ways and I
think it's a kind of a open challenge to
the research community how to build
these systems on greater foundation a
more reliable foundation a related type
of attack is you know data poisoning
attacks which are even a bit more kind
of you know troublesome in some way so
these are when you know attacker is able
to inject or modify training examples
not the test examples and and from the
security point of view this is kind of
interesting because usually you think of
security is you're trying to keep people
out you just keep people out of them you
know you're good but the way that
machine learning works is that you know
you have to let data in right the main
resource that a lot of the you know a
big platforms have is that the users
provide data and that's kind of the key
drivers so now you're kind of have this
tension of how do you keep only the good
data but not the bad data so so I think
there's a bunch of interesting things
there and so a little bit about
reliability which goes back to I think
you know egregious of point is that even
and when you're not dealing with
adversary I think you know there are
cases where you know errors may be its
nature and you assume that nature isn't
against you but the stakes are so high
that you kind of want on to be careful
so so this is a there's work by Michael
conductor from you know Stanford who is
works on kind aircraft collision
avoidance you know systems and if you
fly on a plane I think you'll you're
subject to his uh software but recently
he found that you know deep
neural networks actually do really well
at predicting whether two aircrafts are
going to you know quite or not and you
know this might give you the community
some pause because we know that these
models are sometimes can be a little bit
difficult to understand so he's been
developed with others at Sanford
developing tools to actually formally
verify you know properties of these now
network so I think that's kind of those
types of things are interesting and I
guess a final remark is on the idea of
control I mean I guess in a different
sense than when you mention it is you
know if we think we're building systems
with certain behaviors and the whole
mantra of machine learning is that the
behaviors are defined in the data so
whereas before you might have had kind
of a more node if you had a rule or some
sort of declarative way to specify
something you could you know maybe have
direct access but if it's in a data we
now need to build tools to actually be
able to change the behavior according to
what you want in the data and so with
that I'll stop since my time is up ok
thank you thank you to see as long yeah
thanks so much privilege to be back it's
in two weeks since I push Microsoft and
it's a nice occasion to come back so
actually I'll try to build a little bit
on what but firstly just said and you
know a way I've thought about this which
is maybe a little bit too cute is that
in some cases machine learning has
turned out to be too human in the sense
that it sort of reflects and reproduces
a lot of the deficiencies and problems
of human reasoning and then in other
cases it's - it's insufficiently human
we don't really understand the way that
our reasons and so it makes us hard it
was hard for us to understand what's
going on or feel comfortable with it and
so I'll start with the first and then
try to move on to the second so so in
what way is we she'll only potentially
to human and I think what Percy was just
mentioned the end is an example of that
which is you know we're training often
on documented cases of human behavior
especially when we're trying to make
important decisions in these high
consequence areas like Employment
Security credit all these domains which
were often really complex bureaucratic
procedures that involve some degree of
automation but increasingly stand to be
pretty rather you know pretty
significantly revolutionized by machine
learning and I think people have been
rightfully pretty enthusiastic about the
potential benefits this will have not
just in terms of accuracy and efficiency
but also in advancing financial
inclusion improving civil rights all
these kinds of issues but what people
have discovered is that because were
often learning from history from past
examples these systems are very
vulnerable to inheriting a lot of the
problems that we are documented in these
examples and so this is become a really
I think pressing problem and this
concern around buying machine learning
has in a pretty short number of years I
think become a pretty pretty widely
accepted and recognized issue that has
invited a lot of researchers to try to
tackle it but it's a difficult problem
and I would say that the the kind of
research field has bifurcate at this
point and I'll just really explain the
bifurcation to show so there's one
theory work which is focused on the fact
that maybe our models that we build are
doing really really well for the
majority of the population but maybe
don't do terribly well for the minority
population and so the aggregate reported
accuracy of performance overall might
seem great but if you actually separate
out how the model is performing for
different parts of population what you
realize is that some population is just
being assessed much less accurately than
another right and and that alone might
just be a first analysis that should
encourage us to ask why for the case and
and people are thinking about those
types of situations in fact what Eric
was mentioning at the start of the day
yesterday about this ProPublica story
involving the recidivism prediction tool
was an example this where the tool was
sort of making errors in different ways
with making more false positives for
black defendants and more false
negatives for white defendants and it
was just a disparity and the rate of
which these errors are being made that
actually led people to sort of wonder
like is this actually fair despite the
fact that you might be able to say that
the reported accuracy so the true
positives been true the true negative
rate was comparable right so this isn't
I need us to think a little bit more
deeply but if we just aggregate these
metrics do we actually discover that
there is there some unevenness here
along the lines of race and gender and
these other protected characteristics
but separate from that is this even more
pernicious problem where sometimes we
don't even know that our models are
actually doing a worse job for some part
of population because we have a sampling
bias or because the actual examples in
code past discrimination for example I
give of this is if you want to train a
model to predict who will be a
productive employee we might use past
examples of employee performance as
recorded in their annual review right so
we assign a score to people to end the
year we look at the features associated
with that particular person and we try
to find other people those features that
correlate with the hype you know the
high score but if that score was made
with a sign if the label of a given for
example was done in a prejudicial or
biased way we actually don't even know
the ground truth note is we will instill
we have is this highly biased set of
examples which the machine will take is
true and so our evaluation will not
reflect the fact that the predictions is
making don't actually correctly predict
how the people will perform but it's
correctly predicting it's how they will
be labeled prejudicially by a human
right so there's all these really tricky
problems in that case where it's not
even necessarily obvious when we're
making these kinds of errors and then
it's a less tractable less structured
problem and that also is a really I
think important area of work so their
main time with this shift to this other
point which is that maybe you know a
different issue is that we just don't
even understand how these systems work
maybe we don't see them as actually
following the same kinds of heuristics
that humans might so that it actually
makes it difficult for us to have any
intuition about whether the decision was
made in a fair way and so there's a
growing awareness of this looming
regulation in Europe called the general
data protection regulation the thing
that this community has become
particularly sensitive to is this
requirement which has been sort of
stalled the right to explanation I just
want to say that it's actually worth
noting that there are existing legal
requirements in the united states that
require explanation so there are laws
that actually govern credit
and if you apply for a loan I doubt
anyone this room had this happened to
them but if you applied for a loan and
you get rejected the creditor the lender
actually need to tell you why there's a
legal requirement to explain and this
requirement is actually structured the
industry quite quite significantly such
that a lot of the more sophisticated
machine learning techniques that we talk
about here are not widely used in
industry precisely because it makes it
difficult to produce these kinds of
explanations but I think it also prompts
us to ask what we want to get out of the
explanations why do we want explanations
a common response to this is that we you
know watch we have expectations of being
explained decision by a model when we
don't even have that with human
decision-making and I think the answer
there is that we have really developed
institutions for when important
decisions are made such that people
actually have to justify them right so
it may be that humans justification for
their decisions only loosely related to
the actual reasoning that led to that
determination but we as humans have
intuitions about that right we have ways
of trying to probe and get a sense about
whether or not this person is in fact
giving as a satisfactory answer and in
cases of legal decisions it doesn't even
really matter what the reasoning was in
the judges head it actually just matters
what's produced in the stated written
document because that will that is what
will be debated at a higher court right
so there's really important values
involved in making and offering
explanations but we need to ask whether
those things are the most of the right
mechanisms to defend and vindicate the
values we really care about when it
might be less about you know trying to
inform someone about how you change
something to get the credit than it is
about ensuring that these models are
fair that are not that are not
discriminating and I just want to end by
saying that a lot of the work that's
been done on trying to deal with the
problems of bias and machine learning
can themselves be a way of ensuring and
certifying that these models actually
meet some kind of formal definition of
fairness which might be a more effective
way of getting at these questions than
explanation thank you so much
Kyla well this is a very exciting time
for AI say I you know permeating our
lives revolutionising our lives and
we have you know self-driving cars we
have speech automated speech recognition
so clearly AI is benefiting dramatically
society and is benefiting pneumatically
business companies etc my concern is
that maybe we are not doing enough for
nai
we are not using AI for addressing other
concerns such as the sustainability of
our planet so you know over the last
10-15 years I have you know immersed and
deeply and I've been deeply involved in
nurturing new field Eric mentioned that
the field of computational
sustainability and you know the big
picture is that we should harness AI and
computer science techniques to address
key challenge sustainability challenge
and you know challenge concerning
sustainable development and you know
there are many opportunities where we
can actually make a big difference we
have you know I thought I would give you
some examples of how we can really have
tremendous impacts for example you know
as you know since the Industrial
Revolution the reduction in biodiversity
has been dramatic and so for example we
have collaborating with the Cornell Lab
of Ornithology they have you know in
this incredible program for citizen
science boards where you know anybody
can contribute to submit the world
observations and we using AI techniques
using you know machine learning we can
now we have now very detailed models of
how you know species distributions and
the birth distribution models that you
know really allow us to use
fundamentally new ways of doing
conservation for example the Nature
Conservancy is using these detailed
models to to protect the birds against
the drought
you know migrating birds in California
by basically creating these rivers
options where you know farmers are paid
to keep water in the rice fields
providing habitat for birds when they
are migrating you know and this is only
possible because we are using this you
know sophisticated models you know the
same way Wall Street uses sophisticated
models to predict when birds are
migrating and creating habitat for birds
so this is an example but you know
another area where I think AI can really
make a big difference is in terms of
scientific discovery for example we are
working with the Joint Center for
artificial photosynthesis context to
accelerate the discovery of new
materials for renewable energy in
particular for solar fuel for fuels are
you know promising because we can store
the solar fuel and you know and this is
actually very exciting for AI because
you know we want to use our machine
learning models to for example a key
problem is how can we infer crystal
structures from from x-ray diffraction
patterns and you know this is a problem
that is similar to topic modeling except
here we need to you know obey the laws
of physics so you need to you need to
reason to reason and infer you know
these complex physical constraints and
so your solutions have to be
need to physically meaningful
interpretations of your data and you
know this is a challenge for machine
learning so so I think this is an
exciting topic and in fact for example
using AI system that we deploy that's
all tech and it's also at the
synchrotron our collaborators have been
able to you know discover a new solar
light absorbers so I think there are you
know Mike I wanted to end emphasize a
bit more positive note of course there
are many concerns and we need to address
you know including for example
unemployment ice alternation leads to
unemployment so we need to think about
solutions and and AI can play a big role
but also I think you know it is a
societal issue that you know we may need
to think of the you know new ways to
address this challenge but you know my
my big message is that you know we can
use AI for a better world grateful well
thank you Carla we're just open up to
questions now I'm discussion out but
I'll start by just proposing an
opportunity to Salonga they are a large
consortium of companies Viking companies
and NGOs and nonprofits working together
wants to develop a best practice for how
classifiers are fielded and may be
tested for fairness before the put out
in the world and they come to you and
they say well what should we do
yeah so it's interesting because this is
actually something that a lot of
regulatory bodies are also considering
and so it's probably a good idea that
industry itself is considering this for
the input from other stakeholders you
know I think that the problems are not
yet so fully understood that it would
make sense to say that if you meet this
threshold
in the queer I think at this point it
makes much more sense to say that
there's some floor that you should at
least try to meet and it doesn't
guarantee that you'll avoid any kind of
problems in the future but that this is
considered best practice and you really
should try to at least get to that point
and I think there there's a lot of stuff
that actually you know I think what this
reveals is that there's a lot of issues
around safety and reliability that are
very similar to questions of fairness
right they're sort of about sinking Bay
carefully about how your model is going
to perform in real circumstances trying
to do a good job of considering like the
Train did you using to actually develop
these models things that I think you
know people are already pretty well
attuned to but you could give it a
special kind of inflection by making it
also not just about liability generally
but about making sure that that it's
reliable along these lines that really
matter given historical and equities and
society so I think to the degree that we
can already provide that kind of
guidance that really probably resonates
with frontline engineers I think that
would be enormous ly helpful even if
that doesn't mean that like you're in
the clear for any kind of legal issues
you might encounter despite your best
efforts I know when I read that pública
piece I couldn't get past the sense that
the data set being used across North
America was was was derived from data
from one city I said forget about
everything else I said how could that
possibly admit in medicine you would
never do such a thing
and even though that wasn't even
mentioned as a big issue in the article
so that that's a comment there on those
practices any questions from the
audience or comments people are just in
stunned silence we have one over here I
think Burton
should I just thought wow threatening
what you're known to not need a
microphone
go ahead strike is interesting about the
problem fan learning by artificial
intelligence we have we have an example
of this in the movie literature the most
famous artificial intelligence that most
people know on the planet is named
Pinocchio Pinocchio had a conscience
maybe Jiminy Cricket who continued to
train the artificial intelligence in
morality and right thinking and all
sorts of other stuff
wall-e was running around in the world
why don't we do something like that we
do that with our children too why don't
we do something like that with the
artificial intelligences that we
deployed for funding profit now I you
just a clarify Burton are you saying
that the Jiminy Cricket module is also
AI but somehow it's a really good that
suspected with respect to both that's
where the AI system I think yeah I think
I think Jimmy cricket is trustworthy
because have you ever noticed Judy
cricket seems to know everything but
never changes his mind or has any sort
of insight it's just the way things are
a bit archival Fetty video they directly
you just shut off is to build off
Germany's ability to learn these things
and that way jiminy stays trustworthy as
an advisor to Pinocchio about the
eternal verities I'm just wondering
whether we ought to get a little more
creative about layers of things
including layers of meaning by the way
layers of well this is true because that
is true because that is true because we
learned it that way in layers from
whatever train this person or other AI
so I think that's a really nice point
and I think we are seeing to some degree
AI is evolving in this direction and the
first example that came to mind when you
brought up the two AI is competing
against each other was actually the
generative adversarial networks where
you basically have you know one network
that is trying to
fool the other Network and the other
network that is you know putting the
first Network kind of back in its place
and we're seeing a lot of really cool
things that are that are emerging as a
result of this and I feel like it's only
kind of the start of something that
that's going to be much bigger so I
think it's a really cool idea and I do
hope that they'll be much more work
building on this it's been also rising
discussion about this idea of a
meta-level reasoner that watches over
things and have some simple rules it
looks for simple problems it looks for
and there's a field called runtime
verification RV which has come to the
fore with ideas that look you can't the
complicated thing we're relying on we
had to build because it was
sophisticated we can't really verify
this thing but we can verify on monitor
that could look at this thing and at
least watch for out of bounds that kind
of thing might be more inbounds ed here
Oh a summer vehicle firstly I got Paul
protocol here cope good Kishore Namit
original JJ I just wanted to point out
that you know Jerry Salter in his 1974
seminal people on security and privacy
pointed out that the goal of a secure
system should not be to prevent all
violations because it's just not
possible to know all the violations that
are possible and so the panel that Percy
was was mentioning about the security in
NII one of the things that came out was
the fact that we don't really understand
how the AI program is producing the
results are in producing and therefore
given that setting how can you even
think about how to build secure ni
systems because we don't know what the
correct behavior should be we may not
all know all the correct behaviors and
so how do we know whether when things
are happening that are violations of the
correct behavior that's exactly what
Janus also was cautioning against that
if you know that there are violations
happening you can detect it and try to
build a technique for that but with the
end systems how do you do that is that
something that the panel can address
yeah so that's a very good point I think
you know there's a there's always a gap
between kind of theory what you can
prove and what's happening in reality I
think with AI systems there's kind of a
greater gap because you know a lot of
machine learning is based on kind of
induction induction you know you kind of
have to take this leap of faith which
means that you can't always just fall
back to you know certain principles so
you know I'm writing down this
optimization problem and I can solve it
therefore I trust the results as long as
the solver is kind of you know verified
Uruk and correct but you know this
induction leads to problems like what is
the inductive bias and this gets to
issues of kind of bias that Sloane was
mentioning and I think this is still
very kind of early as you know in the
kind of intersection between security I
think one of the great themes to move
forward with this having the two
communities talk to each other more
because I think there could be kind of
additional structure inside kind of
these AI models that could be kind of
made more secure
whether it be I'm just verifying or you
know trying to understand existing
models or finding a kind of a different
class of models which might even work
better so one of the interesting things
that one notes is that when someone
tries to make their systems secure by
stability of adversarial training
against adversary examples it actually
produces a more accurate models in some
cases and so it might be the case that
having a stronger you know bar actually
can you know increase a variety of
different objectives over here and then
get it over here so people down here
hello I'm Pablo Perez from Stanford
so I'm actually wanted to change the
problem will with the notion of we've
been talking about sustainability what
about the sustainability of AI itself
because I think there are two
fundamental fuels that that AI depend on
one is data and the other one is talent
and I think the data said so far it'd be
very very opportunistic you know you
have all these data set and you go and
work on them and you what about
generating data sets that really matters
just generating data set is not a
trivial problem like should we work on
actually sustaining the growth of AI by
creating the right data sets not yet
finding data sets that are lying out
there and the second one talent is lots
of AI tell and it's going to go to make
one more advertisement being delivered
at the right person making more sense
for the same institution why don't we
get more talent working in the right
province with the right data sets so are
we actually working on the
sustainability of AI from that movie
comments anybody I can talk a little
guys about the data sets someone can
take a second Park so it it's a very
good point that a lot of the progress in
AI has been you know fueled by these
data sets I mean where would you know
computer vision be if for deep learning
for that matter if you know imagenet
haven't you know been around and I think
traditionally at least in machine
I mean data sets haven't really gotten
as much kind of you know people great
data's haven't gotten as much you know
credit to traditionally because the
emphasis was on you know what is the the
secret sauce what is the algorithm or
the model that's going to make it work
but you feel like things are you know
changing especially in this era where
people I think realized the you know
importance of these datasets and you
know at least in kind of vision and NLP
people have been creating a lot of
different you know finding creative ways
to create a lot of different datasets
and every time that happens there's
often kind of you know progress being
made it is worth thinking about you know
whether once you kind of create just
work on data sets which are happen to be
therein or expedient or whether one
cares about finding particular types of
problems that we really believe we
should work on for example in you know
sustainability or you know maybe
something that involves you know fake
nusers or security and maybe with the
more of incentive to create datasets
people actually step into these data
scarce areas okay so it was a difficult
I could answer the second address
without that was a nice multi image the
second aspect it just reminded me of one
of the undergraduates I was working with
when I was a graduate student Berkeley
she came to me after I was teaching a
class and she said you know I really
like what you're doing and I want to
work with you but I'm a chemistry major
and I am going to be a chemistry major
because I don't want a job where all I'm
going to do is sell at and so computer
science is boring and useless and I
don't want to study it and I want to
study chemistry so I just want to bring
this up to say that I think that
students are a great conscience and they
are
when really good at pointing you know
people in the right kind of direction
and so I'm personally not super worried
about people just wanting to sell more
ads and I was really excited also to
hear
Barbara's discussion yesterday about her
class around ethics and I've heard many
discussions of these new classes coming
up at various universities around the
country
and I think having these discussions in
academic circles as well as forums like
this is a really great way to make us
all accountable to each other and make
sure we're on track is we cannot even
hold a panel like this then you know we
know that we're seriously going off the
that where we want to be we can't just
make a comment about the dataset you
know that is quite a very interesting
topic and I just think that our
community tends to you know undervalue
the how how difficult it is to build you
know good datasets and just you know for
you to do to explain this point you know
like my experience working on a variety
of the you know sustainability problems
is like both conservation or for example
now we started a major effort to you
know understand the impact of hydropower
dams in Amazon and they plan to build
over 500 mg 500 amps in the next 10-15
years you know and for us to even
understand the problems it takes even
formulate and pose the questions takes a
long time and and is often you know I
think our community really does not
appreciate all the though the work that
is required to formulate a problem to
you know collected data took to rate the
data and and and you know that is a
important part of our research and
actually I think for us to actually to
have impact we really need to interact
with you know the different domain
experts and and any to it is a process
and you know all these putting together
data sets it is it is very valuable and
I for example when I you know was
chairing this we created a computational
sustainability track for triple AI and
we also created actually a track for
data set papers because that is you know
important and and that's a way actually
to grow the community but sometimes I
think computer science really don't
appreciate that even putting together a
data set is a challenge you know how you
know to address try not to have bias
data sets or so I wish I think we should
really appreciate that a little more
okay thanks : hi Eddie so as we all know
Elon Musk shut up it melted bad AI again
on Saturday okay and I wonder what you
think the community took the computing
research community not just the AI
community can do about this they're a
set of serious issues bias and training
data work force displacement things like
that and it seems to be this alarmism
detract attention from the serious
issues it's not like Eric's Tesla's
going to get together with its comrades
in the Costco parking lot and decide to
turn on us so so I wonder how we
suppress the alarmism without acting
like pollyannas because there are some
serious issues here
it's a responded I mean I did see that
yesterday and we did at folks across
Microsoft X and notes around and saying
well what does this mean how should we
react and policy people and so on
because these statements are taken very
seriously by the public when someone
says I know how these things work I have
deep access and I'm worried I understand
here my first reaction is I'd like to I
felt like an active I want to engage
with Elon and get down to brass tacks
and details
what's the trajectory we're thinking
about was what what's being what is
meant by AI which is a broad set of sub
disciplines might say that I'm really
worried about computer science we need
to make you Latorre activity about
computer science and so I think it takes
coming down to details and engaging
actually rather than saying these people
are off their rockers and but that's
that's been my approach is I try to
understand in detail because my folks
are genuine they have genuine concerns
and if we might be educated by them and
hopefully they might they would be
educated by the discussion and by others
so other comments I'm happy to chime in
too so I mean I think the the sort of
justification for this line of reasoning
when it's academic is that even if this
is like a marginally small risk that it
justifies maybe some small group of
people actually devoting their time to
thinking about it but that's quite
different than when you have these
important figures in the field who are
speaking I think to to you know policy
makers and so I think there's certainly
room for this kind of rain
of concerns academically speaking but I
think we want to make sure that the
people who are in front of policymakers
or regulators don't sort of push the
issue entirely to this extreme kind of
existential risk question to the
exclusion of these much more near term
and immediate things which maybe don't
generate the same kind of press
fascination but are clearly like very
serious issues that will have profound
consequences for people's immediate
lives yeah number three over here now a
fillip current bill from UT Austin so
what do you think if we continue in the
same trajectory are going right now you
think a is going to make our world a
happier place and if not what should we
do about it what when discussion we had
yesterday was we get into town but to
get together was it was the reflect that
sometimes they'll think about the
problems with a default world today you
know for example there about a thousand
people for reports and studies dying in
hospitals every day in the US alone
because of avoidable human error 100
people of nearly a hundred on the
highways every day in the US alone 1.2
million deaths per years around the
world for car driving by driving cars
it's not that the football world is
perfect we can't you know forward to
think deeply about possibilities of
introducing even error full systems that
might make things a lot better this is a
list of the common rules we were
discussing earlier like what are the
ethics of going too slow with AI per
translating into reality systems we
already know how to build that's what we
actually I won't turn it over to the
panel to react the questions that I
guess that will be happier I mean human
deep I guess I generally I'm optimistic
but I guess it's it's not for free way
it's not that you have to you if we just
not worry about things and you know if
things will go the way we want I think
but I think if we take a lot of these
issues that we've been you know raising
no seriously like you know security
trance
see and these things then I do believe
that you know based on kind of Eric's or
the comments that there's a lot of
things that we can improve now I guess
it's the onus is on us as researchers
and also on I guess people are kind of
communication efforts with you know the
policymakers to kind of make that happen
but so it's kind of a conditional yes
yeah I mean I guess I would say that
this sort of provokes the question of
like what what we mean by happy or who
is funny happy right and I think a lot a
lot of the questions that people have
even these extreme existential risk
questions or sort of about the imprecise
definition of happiness but then lends
itself for this like disaster situation
so you know I think another way of
thinking about that though is that there
are a lot of politics involved frankly
and and the and the metric we're trying
to optimize right and if we don't decide
this in a democratic way or we don't do
it precisely and carefully without a lot
of thought given to many possible
implications then then that's the
problem and so I think like you know I
think it can really be a force for good
but I think we need to actually think
exactly what happiness means here and
for whom right yeah but oh it's like oh
okay
let me sings over your head weights also
so set out back when you're done okay
I just wanted to get back to this
previous question about this whole
existence of risk aspects I do think I
mean I really like the way I'd put it I
pretty much almost said similar things
to some reporter asking me about these
issues I think it's okay for some few
people to be worried about this but it's
important for us to point out to the
community to the outsiders that they
really the technical community is not at
all you know obsessed about this and in
fact they've been very little traction
you know for these kinds of worries it's
just that you know Outsiders basically
seeing Ellen mask is writing lots of
papers in the eye and
really understands everything about the
eye and it is kind of as much of a forty
seven point five million Twitter
followers he has we do need to do our
part to make sure that the world at
large understands that it's just his
personal opinion and that in fact in
fact if there was some sort of a worry
that vitiated there would have been like
more traction
I mean partnership for AI has a thematic
fillers not a single one is that what is
essential is and well number one is you
what number one is
three honest it's basically it's
understand it's a key critical AI yeah
what I mean either imagine either it's
good right so I think it is important
for us to kind of point that out
otherwise the oxygen would be sucked out
of the room on you know these kinds of
discussions which are actually about you
know important impacts of a I would just
nobody is interested if they're all
going to die anyway you know pretty ugly
death then why care about dinner pyres
and all these nonsense you know okay
not know part great point um this is um
yeah so yeah my question is more
involved in some Bai safety research I
wonder why there's a certain risk that
we in the community I community think
that that we can we can solve these
problems like like for example our
thumbs in bias
you mentioned the parole decision
programs and using your biased data
there are actually a lot of issues there
that that I actually I think beyond AI
researchers and involve more people have
thought about ethics who saw the like
policy sort of what other fields
economics thinks about inequality for
example I wonder where there's a certain
risk that you know as machine learning
researchers we're going to solve these
bias problems and that we actually are
fooling ourselves a little bit that we
should bring in actually a broader set
of experts because I really believe it's
on these phones are not really technical
problems right so no one knowing I
understated said with the should be
science only yeah well so soak up
comments on the interdisciplinary nature
of the work
I'll just quickly say that but it has
been remarkable how much interest is
kind of quickly grown around these
questions within the technical community
alone and it does seem a little scary
that much of the work has sort of run
off without the involvement of a larger
community what I will point out though
is that there's been interesting things
that have come out of the technical work
that have opened up new policy
discussions actually so you might think
that like this is just in desperate need
of long you know millennia of history
from ethics right that the community
would just benefit from the other
disciplines we've thought about this
forever
but there's been a lot of positive
outcomes for that community as well by
having people think very formally
actually about these problems and put
like a very fine point on some ambiguous
thinking and sort of you know like very
amorphous points that have been left
purposely unaddressed in the law also
because like they reflect political
disagreements I like what it's fairness
you know it's not the ethical thing it's
a political thing and the reason we
don't actually resolve once and for all
what it is if you could reflect
different typical beliefs and so what
it's been really interesting I think is
that interaction where the technical
community can actually really make us
think much much more carefully and
precisely about these things which then
also I hope invite in other people as
well
so I'd like to end with a little little
challenge problem to this panel that I
didn't mention earlier it's kind of a
pop surprise reflection and that we will
actually do so I think it's pretty clear
we probably all would agree that there
will be surprises in this field 25 years
from now the feedback will give and say
well that surprised me and that was a
surprise now let's start with Carla and
go down the line here's just tell me
this point five years from now you're
looking back and I asked you future
Carla you just alarm perceived arisia
what what surprising thing happened that
we had not been thinking about with how
machine intelligence but how a I folded
with people in society good or bad
I mean adverse outcome are just fabulous
for the happiness metric we're talking
in here
I just uh you don't want to I just think
about it long and say I have no answer
right now that's funny - it's because
the pop question yeah I you know maybe
related to the previous comment I think
we will have fundamentally different
ways of you know addressing societal
issues and for example an automation
I think automation for us to address the
reality potential and employment I hope
and I hope we have you know different
notions of you know basic income and so
different models of the society I solo
until you see again 25 years now look at
back what's the pie into do you what
really was a big surprise here agentic
there is a positive future here even for
the issues that has concerned me where
these things really are a way to
overcome very long-standing and well
understood problems of human bias and
and sort of the very poor heuristics we
rely on to make super important
decisions all the time and so I I can
imagine with care and thought that a lot
of these decisions are significantly
improved to the benefit of often the
most marginalized or disadvantaged
people in society but I also could
imagine at the same time even while
that's happening for inequality to
actually just become much much more
severe where the distribution of wealth
in society is like further exacerbated
not because AI is unique and being able
to do that but just because it's sort of
feeding into the existing way in which
others already happened and so I just
think many things can happen
simultaneously were you know civil
rights can be advanced even while as a
call that was saying we we find
ourselves in a situation of growing
economic inequality okay so I think
often some of the the surprises that you
get with predicting the future is not
kind of where the technology will land
but how people end up using it for
example in the internet was I guess is a
good example of you know ok well it's we
can you know in 19
eighty or ninety or something you can
imagine okay what if we had all the
computers connected but but somehow that
kind of misses the point of how it
really kind of just changes the way
people interact with each other and you
know communicate and I think you know
it's you know we can project out to the
future I think you know there'll be
definitely a lot more I can embed in our
daily lives I think the um the Machine
human interaction that has been kind of
a theme of that has come ups sometimes
that this summit is going to be kind of
kind of fate almost fade in the
background because you only been noticed
some of these things and so and that
will you know and I think the newer
generation is going to I mean it's kind
of amazing watching some you know kids
kind of interact with these technologies
it's you know you feel like you're not a
different planet or something and so I
think it's going to have you know a lot
of dramatic changes in the way that
people even kind of behave and interact
with each other thank you
oh I guess I'll build on what the other
panelists have said I think it's really
interesting to think about how we will
change culturally thanks to AI for
example you know is this notion of going
traveling to a foreign country and not
speaking the language and stumbling
through this interaction going to no
longer be an issue because we'll all
walk around with a translator app in our
pocket you know does this mean for does
this mean that our language skills are
going to accuracy the way like basic
Edition has atrophied with the
introduction of calculators and you know
I hope that this means that actually
basic education for all of us will mean
you know basic programming skills and
basic computer science will become
really kind of at the forefront because
this will be necessary for every citizen
to really understand what's going on and
hope
we'll all end up being in a closer place
with inequalities or bridging the
inequalities as opposed to exacerbating
them that would be the hope well thanks
to all of our panel members we ended
exactly on time
[Applause]
[Music]